TGIF B 90s are making a comeback and I'm
not just talking about the fashion today
on the day lead any more Justin Bieber
now I'm kidding
just like the Biebs we need a break what
I really want to talk about is this 90s
resurgence aka the best decade ever most
notably did you guys see our beloved
Jack and Rose reunited no not us but
actually Leonardo DiCaprio and Kate
Winslet they hit the stage at the fourth
annual San Tropez gala benefiting Leo's
foundation get you a beautiful friend
who looks at you the way he looks at
Kate now if that wasn't enough they also
reunited with their fellow Titanic
co-star Billy Zane he tweeted this
remarkably dark photo of the three of
them riding gang back together now we're
saving icebergs go figure
so that means I'm definitely watching
Titanic again this weekend and soon
we'll get to see our 90s TV Queen
Jennifer Aniston back on the small
screen it's been 13 years since Jen was
on friends and she is set to make her TV
comeback opposite Reese Witherspoon who
you'll remember play her sister on
friends now according to The Hollywood
Reporter Reese will co-star and
executive produced the series along with
Jen about a New York boring TV show and
I could not think of a better on-screen
pairing which reminds me yesterday I
asked you guys who should play opposite
more herschel Ollie and true detective
season 3 you guys came up with some
amazing options but my favorite picks
Bryan suggested Lupita Nyong'o ash says
taraji P Henson which I fully support
Nathan Drake drew out joel edgerton and
goo cody came up with a good one
Fargo's Carrie [ __ ] I love these you
guys all right be sure to keep checking
back to the e.t community tab for more
polls flashback videos and other good
good all right now sticking with the 90s
thing today
soon we'll all get to watch some classic
TV shows from the decade thanks to Hulu
the streaming service announced Thursday
they are reviving the beloved TGIF line
of your favorite sitcoms from the 90s
get this full house step-by-step perfect
strangers hanging with mr. Cooper and
Family Matters will be on Hulu starting
September 29th did I do that yeah I'm
excited
the announcement is being dubbed ki GI
who and honor of ABC's Friday night
lineup from that decade and as who who
exact Craig Eric put it now it can be
Friday any day of the week on Hulu
cheers to that
now here's something to celebrate you
guys realize it's been 20 years since 98
degrees its first album there are one of
the hottest boy boy bands of the 90s and
lucky for you our very own Sophie
shoelace you just sat down without
Powner of the mouse with anniversary
what's up Greg we're back we just talked
about that they look better than ever
oh my gosh in person let me just tell
you those boys have aged like a fine
wine you so 1987 was the year 93 first
onto the scene with their self-titled
debut album I definitely had it in the
boyband rotating I don't know about you
yeah now they shared some fond memories
from that time with me but what I really
wanted to know was what advice they
would give to their younger self well
there's lots of things
don't take it so seriously enjoy it more
I have more fun with it it's funny
because we tell these stories about 20
years ago and as I'm sitting here
talking about it those were those were
some of the best memories of the whole
ride for me is those early days when it
was just us kind of us against the world
I don't know that we necessarily
appreciated it as much in the moment
because we're so tired and and and so
nervous about what's going to happen but
yeah maybe I have to agree enjoy it
smell the roses okay not often I agree
with this idiot but some stuff will be
more original
[Music]
stay away from Sally she's trouble I
don't have many regrets so yeah well
there was this out wow that's not fair
you know look we took it very seriously
I mean that was our entire lives you
know what I mean and now it's like we're
enjoying it you know take a deep breath
take it in you know we're getting
interviewed still having fun still doing
music together I would've told Mike I
might yet myself 20 years ago change
your hairstyle don't go with it ah that
was the plan that's right some clothing
issues and you had to buy the original I
think everybody went through that though
in the night we was gonna work harder
than others
all right somebody tells me you were a
cute kid in the mind wasn't Donnie I
appreciate the vote of confidence I
really do but I had some interesting
hair we all did and we've all come a
long way since then all right guys from
a 90's boy band to a boy born in the 90s
Hunter Hayes so we just caught up with a
country superstar and you can check that
out on our newest franchise certified
country that's up now with new episodes
every Friday on e teeth YouTube channel
six or something but thanks for having
me to tour the 90s always every day now
speaking of country I've got to share
with you guys this amazing cover of
Shania Twain's that don't impress me
much by none other than our favorite
girls from the valley hi the sister trio
our self-proclaimed Shania fans and took
on the country singers 90s hit for
Australian radio station Triple J's like
a version in a big young fashion
oh boy I'm picking something hill okay
so you're Brad Pitt back don't let see
some likes if you were feeling that
cover and that brings us to my favorite
segment you guys know this new music
Friday
here are the jams I'm adding to my
weekend playlist I'm gonna start things
off with the killers they are back with
some fire new tracks including this one
it's called run for cover and it's well
killer get a Brandon Flowers yeah
alright I also need to give a shout out
to future who just dropped a hot one
with Nicki Minaj aptly titled you the
baddest
[Music]
fatum how I can feature and Mickey all
right but we got to talk about Charli
xcx's new catchy banger boys everybody
is talking about this video mainly
because it features 75 yes
75 of these hottest dudes and music
check it out
Ellis busy I'm trying to be in that
video trying to be I'm gonna put my
moves on Charlie's okay guys if you can
believe it there are so many more voids
in that video and we've got a full
breakdown over at each I'll I'm calm
it's Friday I am still in silly are you
guys if you haven't already subscribe to
e t--'s YouTube channel do it now
because how else are you going to know
what's going on with Justin Bieber
alright I'll see you guys on Monday bye
boys